نحن هنا امام بلديه الشماليه كوسوفو حيث
ينتشر جنود من قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه
التي يقودها حلف شمال الاطلسي وقد ازالوا
اسلاكا شائكه كانت موضوعه هنا خلال
الاسبوع الماضي وازالوا معظمها بقي هذا
الجزء اليسير منها وضعوه جانبا فيما يبدو
انه اشاره على تخفيف
لتقديراتهم الامنيه بشان التوتر هنا ولكن
حقيقه بواعث التوتر ما تزال قائمه هؤلاء
المحتجون يواصلون تظاهرهم وتجمعهم في
المكان ويطالبون بازاله هذه العربه على
وجه التحديد هذه عربه شرطه كوسوفو التي
يطالب هؤلاء المحتجون بانسحابها وانسحاب
غيرها من العربات التي لا تستفزهم ولكن
حكومه كوسوفو ترى في وجود هذه السياره وفي
وجود شرطتها هنا ممارسه
لحق سيادي وهذا امر مرفوض بالنسبه لهؤلاء
المحتجين الذين يوجهون ولائهم وانتمائهم
في هذا المكان الى بلغراد الى صربيا هذا
المحتج للتحدث مع جنود حفظ السلام الذين
يبدو انهم بداوا الان ايضا بازاله الاعلام
الصربيه من هذه الحواجز التي ما زالت
موجوده هنا محمد المدهون الجزيره من بلده
زفيت شان الشماليه